c'est le toucher des pêcheurs de trésors
là aujourd'hui je suis avec alex
toujours mon pote et sa famille donc on
va pêcher un endroit très compliqué
parce que des troncs d'arbres des
rochers et ses profonds mais l'avantagé
c'est que ces spots à haut taux de
criminalité on va dire on sait qu'il
s'en faut trouver des armes et des
coffres forts
donc c'est parti pour la pêche mon
premier mari j'ai déjà un gros plus
[ __ ] partants qui la traitent à des
trompes tu ma chronique web pour le blog
débloqués par la shdm maintenant une
poche ou encore extincteur avec la forêt
de puck pour un premier lancer ouah
d'eux même pas l'expérience et du gaz
d'une bonbonne de gaz
bon c'était accroché son ensemble a mais
ici il doit y avoir des trucs chelous
non non
saleh avait plein presse high liner web
arba ici on va vous faire des conneries
est-ce qu'on a de boer c'est ça
j'ai pas trop ce que c'est ce truc c'est
juju rasta un chiffre on c'est dégueu a
ouais j'ai un gros truc qu'on regarde
c'est quoi un saut de bagnols pas mal on
va danser watts à petit col en v nickel
1 1
un porte manteau un sound
à quoi
un bon cadre cadre de scooter comme neuf
mais j'ai l'impression gloire veut ça
conserve mieux que le canal sans quoi
paris
ouais je pense et je sais pas si
j'allais moi une poche elle dit
il te mange le dos on va juste et très
loin pour voir sa bouche on est bon
alors roman tunnel de voiture et je suis
à toi c'est la même
c'est la même temps peut-être une partie
plus grosse lose my body soul allemande
sentir bien ou des proches pensent toi
ces camps respectifs à un [ __ ] scooter
scooter parallèlement je suis flic ça
soulève un peu la voix lors il va
arriver en vrai que s'il tire l'arbre
derrière ça va on est bon la lande être
pas mal
ah là là c'est de te coûtera parce qu'il
y avait des tâches descente
hinton une top 6
quand vraiment on est un bloc d'acier au
bout quoi ça soulève intensifs il est
lourd et bloqué le nom vas-y se sentir
de ce côté je pense on sort de là il
vient de débloquer de l'ordre tandis on
voit encore là où elle est belle elle
est magnifique on est alors à temps pour
rattraper l'arrière
ouais
les vieilles c'est là un bon taux
ressort sinon on voit les belles lé bon
style est aussi celle ci part entière
c'est quoi c'est une cassette les normes
et une chaise selon lui grâce à michel
sardou
[Musique]
voilà on en a le nom de la personne là
pascal perez le propriétaire peut être
atteint 104 104 g la même d'accord bon
ben il en modifie en fait ces deux là il
ya un truc que jo est là il ya un
peugeot 104
j'espère que je vais pas le rater mais
j'ai fait une trouvaille de flou qui
retombe et aller je le chope et quand
même ga barbarians ah ah ah ah bon
ouais ouais ouais alors tu en voilà
n'échappe pas non non non c'est pas vrai
beaucoup de gamers gamer republic of
gamers comme neuf
ça ça vaut 2000 euros public home games
l'a regardé maintenir le gagnant 2000
euros ça i7 et bien fun change de pc ça
tombe bien moi non mais là c'est parce
que tu récupères je suis un vieux pour
un gaming taddei 9 ans en formant points
comme ça je te le fais moitié prix du
neuf on va investir 2000 bâle attaquera
la légende priverait appris il a pris
cher il sent reconditionnés ouais
reconditionnés ce soit 2000
non votre le proprio par contre
peut-être avec les numéros
ouais c'est ça il ya peu de chances
qu'il soit maire très bien enfin ces
avances aux de bagnols encore
ça c'est quoi ça c'est du 44 magna non
ça c'est du 44 magnum moyen du 45 à cp
peut-être jeudi à 16 h 45 quand même
ouais ouais ouais c'est ça voici donc
les munitions retrouvées
donc c'est bien du 45 à cp et elles sont
toutes datées de 1942 donc seconde
guerre mondiale ce sont des balles
blindés on voit que le blindage et un
peu partie à cause de l'eau donc ses
munitions ils ont pu être utilisés pour
des colt 1911 mais c'est pas le cas
parce que je connais les personnes qui
ont retrouvé l'armé ce cadre là et vous
n'allez pas y croire mais il s'agit d'un
authentique thompson donc celui ci bien
sûr c'est une copie les personnes qui
l'ont remonté montré des photos elle
était plutôt bien conservée donc je
pense qu'elle a été jetée bien après la
seconde guerre mondiale avec avait un
chargeur plein et un vide
c'est une arme emblématique des années
30-40 donc superbe travail bravo
attention aux rastas d'impôt au mieux
mon petit loin
au du cuir ça on aime une belle bobines
des familles al hayya lyall fois agen
truc
oh no oh oui alors de pêche alors
troisième quart d'heure ben oui voilà
qu'est ce que c'est encore un moteur
moteur de 14,2 à un solex moteur solex
pas mal les world sera d'avoir tissé
voiture ou s'il te plaît à aa
j'aime le truc prière javaux truc
ouais ouais effectivement qu'ils
accolent noens et l'autre partie non
c'est l'autre moitié ne s'est pas voilé
pas très bien
c'est pas le même d'accord ça c'est un
appareil photo je crois c'est vieux
d'appareils mais vraiment l'ancien as a
recensé un morceau de la blanche
non anon tient sa tante à l'intérieur
non il ya un truc dans le sac il ya
trouvé le sac ça ça peut c'est un peu ça
peut laisser un obus non au nom de la
mère allez c'est parti
t'as vu c'est compact au nom encore
faire
ses rails on les prend enfin à ça c'est
pour tirer ça aurait ces câbles pour
tendre on peut pêcher avec [ __ ] le
poids qu'il va y avoir ça en rêvant
courant va laisser dans tous les cas
mais faut essayer de prendre le pas que
les gens les rejette quoi patrie la
rigolade à côté
il était la pêche deux minutes il fait
un moteur de scooters première fois
qu'ils passent à moi je dis ça je dis
rien c'est qu'elle est le sac aussi va
nous faire plaisir encore une fois on le
remplit donc la nouvelle sortie un
bowler de pêche et la boulette et ils
ont tous un petit canon de fusil à pompe
bon il est dieu très pure ones et il est
un des deux états 3 sets à 0 12 ça m'a
dicté à la licence de tir comme
échapperait en poudre au nord qui peut
encore tirer avec mais je mettrais pas
des balles récente quoi on va voilà
cette vidéo touche à sa fin donc on a
remonté dit très très lourde alors
aujourd'hui montrent leur retard voilà
donc va falloir mettre ça dans la polo
ça va être plusieurs vols aller-retour
ce sens mais on va évacuer et on va
vendre tous offert ailleurs comme
d'habitude un petit port de pêche pour
la fin aller à la prochaine
[Musique]
m
ce soir
[Musique]
bon bah comme vous pouvez constater tous
les composants intérieurs sont morts
qu'ils ont beaucoup trop rouillé donc à
rien qui est récupérable à part
peut-être le plastique et les touches du
clavier
c'est la seule chose qu'on peut
valoriser